[Musica]
chi di noi e contro la legalità nessuno
siamo tutti per la legalità perché la
parola legalità tranquillizza legalità
già a pronunciarla ti senti un po a
posto il problema è che fatichiamo un po
a declinarla in prima persona ci piace
tanto solo quando è la legalità degli
altri quando chiediamo rispetto per le
regole
tu e gli voi essi io oppure noi ci
escono un po fuori con difficoltà perché
ogni tanto
insomma la coda agli sportelli la
saltiamo parcheggiamo in doppia fila
chiediamo anche qualche favore non è
proprio una raccomandazione solo che
sempre meglio conoscere qualcuno e poi
in fondo dai è l'occasione che fa l'uomo
evasore come quando l'elettricista
esordisce con quel sarebbe strizza
l'occhio e ti suggerisce un po quel
dribbling d'imposta pagamento in
contanti senza prove tutti
maledetti e subito sarebbe in quel
condizionale c'è tutta la seduzione
l'inganno perché alla fine se vuoi la
fattura il conto diventa enorme e allora
quel sarebbe diventa sono e paghi e la
morale del motorino andrea camilleri la
genialmente teorizzata perché con il
motorino tu puoi evitare la fila poi
destreggiarti tra le auto puoi anche
passare con il rosso tanto con il
motorino sia facilità di manovra
puoi andare pure contromano fai lo
slalom insomma si fa quel che si vuole
fregandosene delle regole che anzi
diventano un po un elemento di fastidio
di disturbo e quella gincana tra
specchietti e paraurti provoca invidia
ma camilleri non poteva immaginare che
la metafora del motorino sarebbe stata
surclassata da un mezzo ancora più
subdolo in monopattino elettrico a nolo
tu li vedi a bruxelles e dc bella novità
perché li usano come bici
nelle piste predisposte secondo le norme
previste
certo qualcuno parcheggia anche male
però insomma nessuno osa cavalcarlo
nella gran plus o nelle zone riservate
ai pedoni
perché i pedoni sono una cosa e i mezzi
di trasporto come la bici o il
monopattino un'altra e diciamo che
questo a bruxelles è chiaro a tutti
dopo il lock down il monopattino è
arrivato anche a roma
un inno d'anarchia trovare piste
ciclabili nella capitale non è facile ma
questo non può giustificare diciamo
l'invasione di ogni spazio marciapiedi
la ztl l'area pedonale al calar delle
tenebre è uno sciame che non conosce
sensi unici semafori due tre occupanti
sul monopattino un giocattolo ho vissuto
con il gusto del luna park
peccato che l'auto scontro sulle auto
finisca diciamo per scontrarsi davvero
prendere travolgere i pedoni come dei
birilli in via dei fori imperiali sul
lungotevere ci sono i vigili carabinieri
la polizia fermano i monopattini in due
non si può queste la ztl è la replica
dei pischelli ma anche di quelli
professional romani o turisti padani è
simile questo monopattino elettrico come
se il fatto di essere una novità per di
più ecologica lo rendesse extra legem
con licenza di fare tutto quello che ci
pare ed al monopattino si sale di skara
chiudendo gli occhi quando fa comodo le
regole le osserviamo quando ci conviene
solo se ci tornano utili
siamo un po i cittadini ad intermittenza
la legalità è un dovere da ricordare
agli altri e dal quale sfuggire noi
stessi e poi se la maggior parte delle
persone non rispetto alle regole
alla fine ma perché dovrei farlo io
essere onesti non è che serva a cambiare
le cose
in fondo o chi me lo fa fare
noi vediamo lo stato con un dominatore
ci impone delle regole per fregarci per
sfruttarci come qualcosa di distinto e
distante da noi
e allora amici impegno e alla fine lo
frego io per proteggere almeno me il
diritto del più furbo
fatta la legge mi conviene trovare
l'inganno l'ordinamento giuridico vale
soltanto nella misura limitata al nostro
orizzonte personale e fastidioso
incaponirsi per avere uno scontrino
a volte ci si arrende si rinuncia ma si
legittima l'ingiustizia e la stupidità
verso noi stessi
il fatto è che nessuno può agire per
conto nostro
c'è una saldatura tra responsabilità
degli eau e giustizia del noe quello
dell'evasione è un tema di patto di
responsabilità chi evade ruba due volte
non paga quello che dovrebbe secondo la
legge e prende dal piatto comune in cui
non ha messo tutto quello che doveva un
sistema fondato sull'illecita o si
accompagna a un dispendioso bilancio
dello stato alimentato dalle imposte su
ogni attività lecita è il paese che si
legge sull'illecito raccontato da italo
calvino e nel suo apologo sull'onestà il
paese dei corrotti
al termine è proprio un insospettabile
classe di individui che conquista piano
piano il proprio spazio
la contro società degli onesti coloro
che non per qualche speciale ragione
erano onesti per abitudine mentale
condizionamento caratteriale tic nervoso
insomma non potevano farci niente
saranno così se le cose che stavano loro
cuore non è non erano direttamente
valutabili in denaro una controsocietà
degli onesti che reagisce decisa non
soccombere
immaginiamo di fare il cortile di una
scuola c'è una gara d'appalto per
individuare la ditta che deve eseguire
il lavoro
l'obiettivo è selezionare la migliore ma
cosa succede se si aggiunge
cala gara chi riesce a corrompere un
funzionario un politico qualcuno
potrebbe dire almeno che si faccia e ci
sono stati anche esponenti delle
istituzioni che hanno sostenuto questa
posizione
insomma uno strumento per superare i
problemi burocratici per oliare il
sistema per orientarsi tra le tante
leggi e norme incomprensibili
eppure ci sono molte conseguenze
chi opera onestamente non partecipa o
non vince e quindi non paga gli operai i
fornitori
chi vince non deve dimostrare che bravo
non sarà soggetto ad alcun controllo
quindi non ha necessità di comprare
macchinari di ultima generazione di
avere bravi tecnici non serve la bravura
non serve l'innovazione tanto che nei
paesi dove è più alto il tasso di
corruzione è più basso il tasso di
ricerca e quei tecnici andranno altrove
la chiamano la fuga dei cervelli mentre
vince la mediocrazia della
raccomandazione la corruzione trasforma
i cittadini in sudditi danneggia anche
quelli che non c'entrano nulla nella
costruzione di quel cortile la presenza
di una corruzione sistemica radicata è
la conseguenza di una scarsa
consapevolezza del valore collettivo
della res pubblica
quante volte ci voltiamo dall'altra
parte per proprio tornaconto senza
capire quanto invece la legalità
convenga a tutti
l'evasione fiscale ci costa oltre 120
miliardi l'anno
la corruzione 60 l'economia mafiosa
intorno ai 150 sono cifre da vertigine
sono una montagna di ricchezza e risorse
rapinate un'infinità di opportunità in
meno per vivere meglio il rispetto delle
regole non è un valore fine a se stesso
che si ottiene con la minaccia della
punizione ma nasce dalla cultura e
dall'educazione dalla consapevolezza che
il bene individuale
corrisponde al bene comune la mafia sarà
vinta da un esercito di maestre
elementari spiegava lo scrittore
siciliano gesualdo bufalino perché la
mafia
vince dove vive l'ignoranza il potere
mafioso costruisce il suo consenso dove
i cittadini non hanno più diritti dove
il lavoro la salute l'educazione non
sono più regola ma un ma un privilegio
concesso a pochi da pochi quella dei
diritti è la strada maestra della
democrazia
il problema è che le regole sono la
condizione essenziale per vivere insieme
e servono per dare concretezza e diritti
non si possono rivendicare diritti se
non si rispettano le regole
oggi noi siamo davanti a una crisi
mondiale senza precedenti e l'esperienza
del lock down ha sottolineato come il
rispetto delle regole
il rapporto con i diritti dei cittadini
siano una questione centrale
dicono che sia insito nella nostra
natura di italiani che noi siamo diversi
dagli altri che noi proprio come dire
rispetto delle regole non ce l'abbiamo e
con un osmosi inspiegabile invece di
contagiarci l'un l'altro con gli aspetti
migliori dei nostri caratteri regionali
retaggio di storie antiche e anche di
antiche orgogli sembra che ci
trasmettiamo soltanto i difetti e le
devianze
eppure proprio in questa esperienza di
pandemia
abbiamo rispettato le file abbiamo messo
le mascherine
abbiamo avuto meno negazionisti in
piazza della germania siamo capaci di
dimostrare il contrario
dobbiamo investire su questo senso
civico che abbiamo dimostrato in questo
periodo
ora ci stiamo preparando ad affrontare
uno scenario cupo che ha un solo
parallelo la ricostruzione dopo una
guerra la capacità di superare le
tragedie traendone una lezione oggi la
ricostruzione non deve soltanto tutelare
la salute i redditi deve far leva sulla
legali
e far leva sulla legalità per impedire
che prevaricatori prepotenti e disonesti
si impadroniscano nel nostro futuro
copit 19 ha imposto una nuova scala di
valori ha fatto riscoprire il senso di
solidarietà e anche il senso del dovere
il significato civico del della comunità
non permettiamo che vengano buttati via
noi io non è sì grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]